the Eggman was quite titillated by
yesterday's program calling in about the
interview we did with the car attorney
to 192 david p is the number here's what
the Eggman had to say dave the trump
macaron Daft Punk marching van
video is my favorite one up trump but he
just looks miserable and uncomfortable
during the most awesome song from the
most awesome band the marching band not
deaf market it looks great
I love how uncomfortable he is admit it
that chick was on your balls
okay not on your inner thigh whatever
you're saying and the that interview
it's a car selling lawyer was probably
my favorite one ever I've ever heard I
love that guy it was so informative um
I'm that scumbag that sells used cars
but I guess I've already told you that a
hundred times and um I love that guy
listen man every time I sell a car
I tell people bring a mechanic to my
house know what you can't do you can't
take my car and go to a mechanic and pay
50 or 100 bucks it's a used car from a
guy in a driveway you have to bring a
mechanic with you or good luck right um
hopefully the best customer is one who
brings a mechanic is when they bring one
they always buy it well they don't bring
one they find stuff that does it even
really wrong with the car buyers are
always stupid always stupid yo that
alone brother
hat all right shout out to Pat at the
end there all right so the eggman
hitting all points no I assure you I
told a story about when I was when a
tick attached itself to me after I hiked
a few years ago and I was not cleaning
the story up in any way it was actually
on my left hip period that's it I would
tell you where that word where it was
it's good to get the clarification I
guess and also now we can no we should
not buy a car from Eggman because I will
call you stupid that's the big
revelation do not buy a car from the
Eggman there in upstate New York all
right that's it for today we've got a
great bonus show coming up I hope you'll
join me there david pakman.com slash
membership to get access or patreon.com
slash david pakman show for access